we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 David P
this may be my favorite story about one
of our newest viewers an 81 year old
Canadian grandmother listen to this
found you on Facebook I recently found
out that she watches you every day so
um you can put that in the bank up here
in Canada I love that
um additionally I just wanted to mention
that I really appreciate your slight
comical
um nuances that you have on the show I
really appreciate that because life and
the politics can get so serious very
quickly so I appreciate having a laugh
every day
um when I watch your show well I really
appreciate that and say hello to Grandma
for me I absolutely love that we have a
great bonus show for you today the stop
the steal people
are training so-called poll observers to
wreak complete havoc in November at
polls around the country Dennis Prager
says that there is no secular argument
against incest were it not for religion
everybody would be I guess having sex
with their sister sounds weird
um and then Tulsi gabbard is immediately
jumping into campaigning for a
Republican
she's now an independent she left the
Democratic party but she's not a
right-wing nut but she's immediately
campaigning for a republican okay all of
those stories and more on today's bonus
show don't miss it sign up at
joinpakman.com